I've always had trouble with the
question when people are like what do
you want to be when you grow up it's
just about being open to possibilities
I project images of a pianist the hands
and the body onto the piano it's
projection mapped onto the physical
instrument and this instrument here is a
player piano so the keys move
when you're sitting in front of it it
really feels like there's somebody there
the scenario that I really like to think
about is what it will be like to play
with somebody from the past like
yourself from 20 years ago or your
grandparents when they're at your age
the Media Lab serves as a kind of beacon
for a lot of people that want to build
new technologies and want to see a
different way for us to use technology
we look at all different technologies
not just computers and electronics but
even biology design music how can new
technologies change the way people live
work learn have fun communicate my
research tries to being emotional
intelligence to technology here we have
a camera this camera actually the
history in the faces of people and
analyzing the dynamics of facial
expressions if I'm not smiling and I
have a serious face you see the smile
barometer goes down if I smile then it
quickly goes hi people with autism they
have phones to read the facial
expressions of other people so this kind
of technologies can help them provide
some feedback about that being at the
Media Lab I think is technique
opportunity to explore things you really
have to take advantage of that time
action tab is this mobile app that I
built that allows you to engage in
planning or in response to issues in
your city I get a notification on my
phone I pull it out it allows me to
click through and find a quick one-page
survey there are images that are
associated with those planning documents
and we can embed those in the app and
have people look and consider those
proposals in the space where they would
go they submit that that gets registered
in a database that then the city can
look at and say this is how citizens
have weighed in on this issue and make
that part of the decision-making process
I want to be able to study these things
but also build them and the Media Lab
was a perfect place to combine both of
those efforts cliff makes video content
more lightweight more flexible and more
capable of being distributed to a
variety of new types of platforms some
of which we're starting to see like
wearable watches but some of which we
may not even be able to imagine yet I
hope that video can become more
remixable and that video can be seen as
a material for objects and experiences
beyond our computer screen to make media
cross-platform to make media more
data-driven and more social and more
accessible so much learning happens just
like with your peers and in the
community that the media lab creates I
think the Media Lab is like a very
creative inspiring environment and
there's lots of opportunities to get
involved in lots of interesting projects
scratch is a programming language it
allows kids to create stories games
animations and other interactive
projects scratch is like a digital
version of why go in a way where you're
using these blocks on the screen to
build and design things in the digital
world it's sort of a tool to express
yourself and it's very empowering to be
able to create and share things online
with other kids
we have about thirty research groups at
the lab and when the student applies
they have to decide which of those
groups they would be a good fit for my
PhD project is about designing
comfortable prosthetic sockets the
socket is usually hot and made out of
carbon fiber we know what the body's
made up
I mean study that model that so that we
can tease out a bunch of force
displacement time curves which we can
use to model the predictive nature of
the soft tissue it's really necessary to
act as a bridge builder between
different fields and I think the Media
Lab is a perfect place to do that for
anybody who feels like they don't quite
belong solidly in the middle of any
field but they see the connections
between different things and they want
to explore those connections for and
there's always this like really
supportive environment that tries to
optimize for learning I've been at Media
Lab for 25 years and I can't imagine
being anywhere else it's just an
incredibly vibrant place and creative
place and every day you learn about
something new and get pulled into new
projects new possibilities